in a significant milestone for
Agricultural Development a graduation
ceremony was held to commemorate the
completion of a good agricultural
practices training for over 70
participants of regions 4 and 5. the
training held as part of the second
phase of the enhancement of the
efficiency of the production
distribution supply chain in the fruits
and vegetable sector project more
commonly known as the seven crops
project highlighted the collaboration of
the Taiwan technical Mission and the
Ministry of Agriculture Fisheries food
security and rural development soil
management Pest Control irrigation
techniques post Harvest handling and
Market strategies were among the topics
covered in the training program as
participants gained valuable insights
into efficient production methods and
sustainable farming techniques that
ensure consumers receive high quality
fruits and vegetables ambassador of the
Republic of China Taiwan to Saint Lucia
his Excellency
commended the participants for the
remarkable achievements and emphasize
the importance of the bilateral
collaboration between Taiwan and Saint
Lucia in promoting Agricultural
Development I would also like to express
my appreciation to the Ministry of
Agriculture and Taiwan technical mission
for their hard work on organizing the
washer let's give them a big round of
approach
the government of Taiwan will continue
to work with the government of Saint
Lucia to promote local purchase
Diversified and increase the domestic
production
which comprise the goals of our project
as part of the effort to promote food
security
Minister honorable Alfred Prospect
stated that the
gerv between the Taiwan technical
Mission and the agriculture Ministry
plays a critical role in improving
agricultural practices in our country
according to minister Prosper the
knowledge gained through the training
program will increase productivity
improve product quality and ultimately
lead to better livelihoods for Farmers
this training is in keeping with the new
Frost of the ministry
that is the overarching goal of ensuring
both food security and nutrition
therefore
your added Collective contributions are
essential for improving the food
security status of our nation
we rely on our Farmers to perform that
critical role of wholesome food
production
the ministry is mandate a light of
current world affairs
is of high priority
since several factors such as inflation
the corresponding supply chain
disruptions and escalating prices of
inputs all have driven up the cost of
food and general living expenses
the completion of the training program
marked
celebration and the presentation of
certificates sets the stage for a
promising future in agriculture
strengthening the ministry's steadfast
dedication to fostering a resilient and
sustainable industry of growth and
Innovation from the communications unit
of the Ministry of Agriculture I am
Anisha Antoine reporting